mark best thing about Jeb Bush best
thing about Jeb Bush is a tease of Bush
I'd have to think about that for a
second go ahead take your time all right
I thought about it I think you're
incorrect you think I'm incorrect I
think I'm crazy asian clearly bonkers
how could the best thing about somebody
be being a bush can you imagine the
cojones of this guy who knows what
people associate his family with and yet
he's running anyway what does that tell
you about his strength of character it
tells you he might be having delusions
of grandeur I think I think it tells you
something about you know about Jeb Bush
that's arguably not that bad which is
he's confident enough in himself and who
he is to be able to say I know all that
but you know what I'm going to run as if
I'm going to win I just I think it takes
a lot of it intestinal and testicular
fortitude yeah 22 to do that because
he's not a stupid man at all he
understands that people blame president
george w bush for the morass of Iraq and
for the economic collapse he gets that
yeah uh and he's still running yet which
may be just as you probably did his
family you know it it there's there is
some sense i mean that he might see
himself like Ted Kennedy did is sort of
keeper of the flame in this case
although Ted Kennedy didn't really have
to rehabilitate an image um arguably yep
but but that I jab right but but Jeb
Bush might you know see himself as the
potential rehabilitator of the bush
image which was pretty good after the
first up the first president Bush but I
just think it again it says something
about his his character his
audaciousness that you know his name is
bush and he's willing to run and I think
I think you know it's to me the best
thing about it did we see the most
strange example of that just a few days
ago when he basically said he would have
gone into Iraq and didn't think there
was anything wrong with what his brother
did and then of course backtracked and
now all the Republicans are scrambling
to figure out what their answers I'm by
no means the is is it easy being a bush
running in this race yeah I think that's
what that means but but again I think it
just it takes something exceptional
essentially take what is probably the
most distasteful brand in American
politics and say okay I'm part of that
brand I don't feel good and I'm still
going to do it